je m'appelle valérie à nice ça fait une
année maintenant que je fais de la
marqueterie la marqueterie c'est c'est
une partie de l'ébénisterie il ya eu une
révolution sur la marqueterie avec une
méthode qui a été mise au point par
monsieur bull qui était ébéniste de
louis xiv la marqueterie en métropole
c'est quelque chose de
deux connu à la réunion mois en fait le
cfa de saint-gilles-les hauts il ya deux
ans maintenant a lancé une formation aux
métiers d'art dont la marqueterie et
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert ce
métier c'est un travail de création et
de minutie
on peut pratiquement réalisé tous les
motifs en marqueterie on peut associer
d'autres matières au bois comme la nacre
les métaux comme le letton une boîte on
peut toujours la décorer la marque été
ne serait-ce qu'un petit frisage une
petite un petit décor pour l'instant moi
ce sont les oiseaux de la réunion mais
mes motifs j'ai lancé une collection des
oiseaux réunion j'en suis au cinquième
le dernier c'est le cuicui on part d'un
dessin ou d'un dessin qu'on a réalisé
soi-même ou d'une photo on réalise le
calq pour qu' on puisse avoir juste le
trait toutes les pièces doivent être
fermées ça faire des pièces complètement
fermée pour pouvoir ensuite les découper
une fois que le dessin est le calque son
prêt on choisit ses bois le choix des
bois c'est personnel ou alors c'est par
rapport au dessin qu'on veut réaliser
les lamelles sont entre 6 et 8 dixièmes
d'épaisseur et des bois qui viennent du
monde entier donc des couleurs des
motifs dans le bois qui sont très très
différents vous faites un paquet à dire
que vous collez votre plaquage sur
quelque chose de rigide un carton pour
pouvoir le découper c'est pas très
difficile c'est une question d'habitude
plus on va découper plus on va être prêt
ce nom ça découpe et c'est exactement le
même principe du puzzle sauf que c'est
vous qui avait dessiné vos pièces et
vous les assembler pour pouvoir former
le dessin que vous avez voulu faire une
fois toutes les pièces ont été découpé
assemblé au scotch parce que c'est un
assemblage provisoire on va les
assemblées sur ce qu'on appelle une cale
tendu
c'est un papier kraft qui est temps
collée sur un support de bois médium ou
cp c'est un collège provisoire pour
rassembler les pièces entre elles on
encore la marqueterie dessus avec une
colle vinylique et on met sous presse
entre 4 et 6 heures histoire que
l'alcool soit bien prise une fois que
cette partie là est nettoyé eh bien il
ya le ponçage pour ramener tous les
plaquages a même dimension la face que
j'aime le plus mince et la découpe des
pièces et le montage voir évoluer le
dessin la partie des saints la partie
une création de départ plus le choix des
bois et la découpe des bois moi ce que
je trouve intéressante cette crémer mes
motifs de chercher quelle couleur je
vais m quelle pièce comment je vais
faire ma pièce pour que c'est le rendu
que j'en attends